[Music]
everybody really enjoys working with you
to unset they say you keep the energy up
you keep it fine you keep it light how
do you manage that especially for a
movie of this scale you know the gathers
two of us yeah because when when when
he's exhausted hopefully I have energy
when I'm exhausted hopefully he's got
some energy but yeah so we were very
italian-american so we like we like to
create a family atmosphere we make an
atmosphere where everybody feels like
they belong and like they're
contributing and they're excited and
they're free to to put everything they
have into the work because we you know
it's like it's why we're all here so we
like we like that atmosphere what is it
60 for Marvel characters in this one
it's a lot
we can't keep a realistic count we have
to sit down at some point to have it
yeah yeah it's interesting because it's
our third one with Marvel we know a lot
of the actors and it feels like you're
getting a rhythm and you know as people
come in it's great because they all
bring different energy and new energy to
the set and they're all working on
scenes that are different in tone so it
can change the mood of the day or in so
it feels like there's a lot of variance
as we as we progressed through it or
will work with the guardians for a few
weeks and then we'll get to half The
Avengers for another few weeks and and
so it just keeps a it keeps it exciting
for us and fresh where do the Avengers
stand coming into this film I mean for
us this story has always been a movement
forward from where we left off in Summit
Civil War so you know the Avengers are
deeply divided they have an seemingly
irreconcilable problem and you know
unfortunately that's the moment where
they're the greatest threat they've ever
faced comes to them and it's it's a it's
a bad place for them to be in when that
happens stacks the deck against them I
charge jumping-off point okay well you
know Hemsworth has been so hilarious
about not being in
and that you know and there's this thing
with Evans and Thor and the whole thing
so howdy is that just funny onset is
there that is there funny tension is did
they joke about it you know what I mean
here's the thing we you know not having
worked with that character in Civil War
I mean that gave as storytellers we were
even more excited to work with him in
this film so Thor has a very very
special arc in this movie that we were
really excited about his storytellers
that filmmakers and you know it doesn't
really come up that much sunset I mean
we have a very it's very professional
we're very dedicated to work and I think
that I think that Chris is very happy
with what's happening now when this
franchise started it was nearly 10 years
ago
so this cast has really grown to love
one another they're like a family
they're really good friends and some of
them said you know they get a little
distracted and they're just joking with
one another chatting or something is is
there anybody in particular that you're
like alright come on come on let's focus
that's a really good question I think we
answer this that's the same every time
we're asked it it's probably Anthony man
no he does I mean he's truly one of the
most professional guys we've ever worked
with tonight but I just say that we have
a blast with him we love him here he
brings great energy to set the the crew
loves um the other cast loves them you
know he really he really wants to make
sure everybody's having a good time
these are hard days and long days we're
out here in the hot Georgia Sun shooting
and and it's good when you get to a
Thursday or Friday and Mackey shows up
on set and he just brings a lot of
laughter a lot of fun with him well
that's the thing you got to remember
these actors they're entertainers and
they're great performers and they know
that like these are hard movies to make
like Joe was saying so it's like you
know sort of having a moment of levity
having a moment of fun where everybody
can break for a moment and just get a
little breath of fresh air it's
important and talked about as a
filmmaker these movies pose different
challenges for filmmakers because you've
got the people you've got the
two-dimensional you've got the
three-dimensional but then you've got
the green-screen you've got all the
post-production you've got I mean
there's so many added elements to these
Marvel films how do you navigate all of
that yeah it becomes like a second
nature again after three
movies I feel like we're in a rhythm
with this and it it really does become a
second age you start to understand
exactly where the V effects need to go
on a shot how you're gonna layer it a
lot of times when we're doing work in
the on the script and in a room we lock
ourselves away with the writers usually
for about six to eight months before we
start shooting we go through every scene
line by line and we make sure we
understand what we're all thinking
collectively is a group of collaborators
at what what is happening in the scene
who wants what how we're gonna execute
it visually so we really come to set
very prepared I will say it's always fun
when when you get an actor who hasn't
done a lot of this kind of work before
because it it's a very different
experience you know they have to use
their imagination more in terms of
what's around them and what's happening
and talking to them through that process
I remember in civil war it was around
Winter Soldier rather was Robert Redford
you know sort of like the Virgin to this
process and on this movie Josh Brolin is
really sort of taken to it this is a
brand new experience for him and I think
he's having a lot of fun with with the
whole what what that gives him as a
performer the visual effects dimension
yeah can you believe your job is new
again Scarlett was talking about how
she's so happy there are more women to
balance out all the testosterone talking
about the strong women coming into this
movie as well yeah we have some great
female characters in this Captain Marvel
is in it
Black Widow Scarlet Witch
we have Wakanda is coming in and there's
a whole group of characters that are
coming from the wakandan universe from
Black Panther Universe yes I mean an
amazingly strong character strong willed
characters and you know we have the
guardians and two of the guardians are
our daughters of Thanos so there's a
really strong connection to the main
villain of the story and you know I
think you'll you'll see in the film that
that they're very pivotal to the
storyline and and I think I think the
arcs are fantastic
we're really really proud of being able
to introduce Captain Marvel on this one
yeah and that's the culmination of what
what these have been for years right the
long term vision that's right yes it's
really exciting it really is I mean we
say that you know if you think of the
last 10 years of Marvel movies like a
book this is the end of the book that
we're filming right now so we're and
we're excited to bring that to audiences
yeah yeah talk a little bit more about
Anthony Mackie because you're asking who
was the funniest interview today and I
said Anthony Mackie you know hands down
and he was describing being up in the
harness for six hours straight
you've been exaggerating I don't know
but how everybody you know basically
just laughs at him like being in so much
pain up there talk about that process
and what is actually happening when
Anthony is up in that harness well today
we were shooting him on the in that
harness on those wires today and where
we were hosting him up I said to him go
Anthony you've come a long way since the
first time we put you up on wires
because do you remember when we first
said he was he was terrified on the
wires at the beginning but to be honest
the first shot we ever did with him he
was held thirty feet in the air and we
see yeah we're swinging him in a big arc
it was really it was a long shot but he
got his sea legs you know yeah but you
say his legs have to come up you do a
little bit sometimes to make it work for
the camera we actually pull his legs up
higher than his head and so he can be
hanging up there for 30 40 minutes
that's a lot of blood rush in your head
it's not the most comfortable position
attacked him so you'll see in between
takes he'll just let everything go and
I'll let his head hang because he also
has to lift his head up to face the
camera while he's flying takes a lot of
core strength yeah I think they're out
there
but yeah you know that's all like
Anthony is a great example but these
actors they have to go through a lot of
physical sort of really rigor in order
to accomplish these roles and it's like
Anthony or we Paul Bettany as vision I
mean that's a really intense makeup job
that he has to go into and he stays in
that all day long never complains it's
like the actors are very dedicated and
it's not comfortable so well and that's
experienced too you know anything
and professionalism it's got a good grip
yeah and I think they also love what
they're doing so it helps you know it
helps you push through the hardship I
did sense a lot of gratitude on my men
like they're really you know they're
really grateful for being a part of this
and where they are and yeah they're long
days but I sensed gratitude it's a great
journey to go on together I mean that's
very rare I don't think anything really
has been done like this in the in films
before where you're taking all these
different characters from different
franchises and putting them all together
in a single film and I think and I think
they feel the the weight of that and how
special it is and that it's it's a
once-in-a-lifetime kind of event for us
as directors and for them as actors you
seem so calm about doing that yeah you
have to stay calm because you know if
you let the stress get to you know at
least you and that's preparation -
that's right yeah preparation and
getting rest when you can absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]